okay today's all about healthy food I'm
going to show you that eating well and
eating healthily can go hand in hand I'm
a chef so my whole day not just meal
times is devoted to food if I'm not
cooking it I'm tasting it or thinking
about it my other great Passion life is
Fitness I've run over 10 marathons in
the last 10 years I have to get these
two sides of my life to work together
so get ready for my ultimate healthy
recipes dishes that are good for you
without any compromise on flavor to
start a fresh and fruity breakfast to
set you up for the day quick Birch and
muesli you can make in minutes next a
liquid lunch which is generally healthy
glorious gazpacho soup followed by a
wafer thin pineapple capaccio for
dessert
for dinner it's my youngest daughter
Tilly joining me in the kitchen to cook
up a simple meal packed with goodness
teriyaki salmon filled with Amiga oils
and superfood soba noodle salad
for desserts a delicious light and fizzy
Spritz jelly you would say done this is
my ultimate healthy food breakfast lunch
and dinner first up is my breakfast
Bircher muesli
Bertram usually traditionally gets made
the night before and left in the fridge
I find that a little bit too heavy and
slightly stodgy so it's the same
principles but a lot lighter first in
the yogurt I think live and raw milk
yogurt are best they're packed with
calcium enzymes and probiotics which
help your body absorb nutrients
it's interesting because the kids
especially would prefer their muesli
with milk but the yogurt so much better
for them I like making it literally 10
minutes before I want to serve it
because it doesn't become stodgy yogurt
in apple juice that's a great way of
sweetening the muesli a couple
tablespoons in
give that little mix
now
sprinkle in the oats
I like putting two-thirds in now to
absorb an almost double in size and the
last third of oats in at the end oats
are low on the glycemic index which
means they slowly release energy to keep
you going right through to lunch I quite
like it when it just falls off the spoon
you can see literally in seconds it's
got thicker
the rest of the oats in
so I've got different textures now mix
that up nicely
and it literally takes three or four
minutes to put together
it's gonna get a dry pan on
one's incredibly healthy toasting them
even better flavor
flake them into the pan lightly toast
them
that gives a really nice sort of crunch
to the top of the music
[Music]
roll them around the pan so they're
evenly toasted
out into a bowl
the exciting thing about putting your
own music together is that you're in
control blackberries summer raspberries
strawberries and so it changes berries
don't just taste great they're packed
with antioxidants and vitamin C and K so
just Dot
the top of your muesli with your
blackberries generous on the
blackberries
sweetness tartness
acidic
and then just sprinkle over
your nice almonds
I quite like a lot of crunch on top
so be generous
that looks fantastic
perfect way
to start the day
my quick Birch of muesli doesn't just
taste incredible it makes you feel
fantastic it's my ultimate healthy
breakfast there really is no better way
to start the day
[Music]
next I'm putting the flavor back into
healthy food with a sensational lunch
and dinner
here are the key ingredients you'll need
to cook them
[Music]
first on my ultimate shopping list are
soba noodles these gray brown noodles
are made from buckwheat so they're
gluten free and high in protein
they're quick to cook and so versatile
use them in stir fries soups and salads
like the one I'm making for dinner
salmon fillets are brimming with super
healthy Amiga oils and so quick and
versatile to cook whether poached
grilled pan fried baked or quickest of
all raw or sushi
I'm making a family favorite for my
healthy dinner teriyaki salmon
pomegranates have been revered since
ancient Greek and Egyptian times for
healing properties today we know these
little Jewels are packed with
antioxidants minerals and vitamins b c e
and K they are fantastic in Middle
Eastern dishes or scattered over fruit
salads like the fine pineapple capaccio
I'm making for lunch
I don't believe in fatty diets and diet
foods there's no cardboard tasting rice
cakes in our house let me tell you at
its simplest healthy eating for me is
all about fresh home-cooked food portion
control and a balanced diet and it
should be a pleasure to eat you should
never turn meal times into something you
dread for my ultimate healthy lunch I'm
showing you on my favorite dishes it's
packed with vitamins and goodness but
it's also super tasty gazpacho
for dessert sweet and refreshing
pineapple like you've never tasted
before first job the gazpacho soup
for me the secret of a great gazpacho
is over ripe tomatoes Peppers cucumber a
little bit of heat with the garlic
we've got to leave it to marinade first
Peppers cut around the flat edges to
minimize waste
then chop the nice thing about
making a dispatcher there's no set
recipe because you can put it together
purely all tomatoes
half Peppers half tomatoes
I like the flavor of the cucumber in
there as well that gives it that
freshness
The Secret of a great dispatcher is the
longer you leave it marinating
the better the flavor
so if you can get this done the night
before and left in the fridge
the results are stunning the green and
red peppers have subtly complementary
flavors and go well with ripe Tomatoes
start off by removing the bitter core a
little knife
and just
put it in where the core is and twist it
round and you get this little core out I
remember my first experience
eating a gazpacho in Spain
mind-blowing I've never forgotten that
quarter your Tomatoes keeping the juicy
seeds that add so much depth of taste
nice then from there
cucumber just peel that seeds I'm going
to leave in
that gives it the flavor and the texture
cucumber and gazpacho
does exactly what it does in a pims it
sort of freshens it up
and makes it mouth watering slice that
in half
again into quarters and chop
now to give gazpacho its unique texture
and thicken the soup bread and the
crispy the crust the better then garlic
thinly sliced
next spring onions nice and roughly
chopped and basil stalks and all we can
use stalks and basil stalks parsley
stalks tarragon stalks they have the
most amazing flavor basil in
and now I'm going to start marinating
with salt black pepper and a good
coating of olive oil this gives it a
glossy creamy flavor
and the Cherry vinegar that's the
perfect vinegar
for the gazpacho it's a strong acidic
complement to the flavors
then just mix it up and smell already
it's incredible
it doesn't look
like a gazpacho but by the time this
marinades and all those flavors start
getting to know one another
all of a sudden you've got this huge
explosion of contrast
now
push that down in the restaurants we
press the marinade down overnight a
couple of big pans on top and we Crush
all the ingredients and then Blitz it
the next day
flavor is extraordinary leave all those
fresh ingredients packed with goodness
to marinate from half an hour to even
overnight and then when you blend it
it just comes together like this
Sumptuous Rich delicious chilled soup to
go with my super tasty soup I've got an
ultra healthy and exciting dessert
capaccio of pineapple which is a chefy
way of saying super thinly sliced it's
done with a Twist
we're gonna have a delicious flavored
salt
has to be flavored with vanilla simply
scrape out the vanilla seeds and add to
sea salt along with the Pod to store now
that basically keeps forever there's no
sale by date because it's salt and
vanilla so
so fragrant so delicious you don't need
much of this fragrant salt to intensify
the sweetness of the pineapple
the pineapple
[Music]
sliced peeled pineapple into wafer thin
pieces it's almost a nice little discs
slightly transparent
[Music]
once you've sliced the pineapple take
the flavor to another level
a light sprinkle of vanilla salt and
arrange the pineapple in a flower shape
[Music]
it's a beautiful way of finishing
a meal
fragrance
other than the crunch
with the salt and the vinegar salt just
marinades
the pineapple beautifully then scatter
nutrient-rich pomegranate seeds over the
top to finish finely shredded fresh mint
just
slicing
really thin
and then that'll give that nice cool
minty flavor
a pineapple my Carpaccio is ready and my
gazpacho has been marinating in the
fridge time to blend the soup
um
and
onto your blender
start off nice and slowly
blend until super fine and gloriously
silky and serve refreshingly cold
get your bowl
put it in
to finish it get some fresh basil
roll it nice and tight
shred it
and then drop it into your bowl
fresh
chopped basil and then finally
just a touch of extra virgin olive oil
just to give that really nice additional
freshness
and look at that healthy and delicious
nacho soup to me is a taste of
Mediterranean sunshine in a bowl
followed by the way for thin Carpaccio
of pineapple with jewels of pomegranate
goodness for dessert
quickly all of your five a day in one
incredible healthy lunch
a healthy diet is an important one but
we're pretty relaxed about it my
philosophy is simple try and eat less of
the bad stuff and eat more of the good
stuff and joining me in the kitchen is
my netball nut youngest Tilly for dinner
it's a mega Rich teriyaki salmon with a
buckwheat soba noodle salad brimming
with healthy greens and a light aperol
Spritz jelly for dessert first job the
teriyaki marinade for the salmon silly
gonna help Daddy with a salmon please
right
Teriyaki delicious
sticky sweet salmon okay first of all
I'd like you
a little season on the salmon please
with salt and pepper thank you
all right I want you to slice the garlic
one in front two behind yep
oh oh getting a bit faster in the old
age huh good girl
thank you right garlic in with the
ginger
so we're gonna make a marinade
okay do you know what a marinade is it's
what you coat something in that's right
so let's start off with
soy sauce three tablespoons one good two
good three this is rice wine also known
as Miram one in
I know what that is that's maple syrup
it's a bit like pure pure gold
beautiful and a little touch of olive
oil
it smells really good I want you to rub
the salmon in the marinade if you can
get a chance to do this the night before
the salmon actually changes color but
it's fine even with 10 or 15 minutes
before you start cooking it does the
ginger and garlic give it a different
you know what it helps improve the taste
when we cook it I have this really nice
glaze on there okay right let's put that
in the fridge to marinade and we'll
start the jellies
to follow the teriyaki salmon a grown-up
light dessert Prosecco and aperol Spritz
jelly
start by soaking gelatine sheets in cold
water
poor Prosecco 100 milliliters of water
and caster sugar into the pan heat until
the sugar is dissolved then add your
gelatin sheets
leave the mix to cool top up with more
Prosecco and a dash of the Bittersweet
Italian aperol
foreign
to tumblers over orange slices and leave
to set in the fridge
[Music]
all the refreshment of a spritz in a
perfect jelly form
the Teriyaki Salmon's marinating time to
get on with the noodle and vitamin
packed veg and seed salad
noodles
now this color because they're made out
of Buckwheat
okay and then we're gonna drop them in
so nice and carefree if you slide them
that way
and then you go like that in your hand
and then we'll show you there
and then look
hold them like that and drop them into
the pan okay got them yeah okay so hold
on tight off we go
nice do they take longer to cook than
normal noodles actually take literally
five minutes now what are they
sugar snap peas okay
really crunchy now
carrot and kale
I'm going to show you a really quick way
of slicing carrot ribbons so you just
come down
I was just a bit like peeling number
that's right off you go there we go nice
big long ribbons
sugar snap peas in yeah okay into the
noodles
you've got two
oh thank you wake up daddy next kale now
you know how good that is for you right
yeah kale in right how are the ribbons
they're good oh that's nice
you okay if you like some salt and
pepper a little bit count
ribbons go in
good girl I didn't forget any like you
did excuse me and because we've shaved
them really thinly like this
how long do you think they're gonna take
to cook
about a minute
let's look yummy doesn't it now we're
gonna drain
the noodles
that is beautiful see how the kales go
what happens if you cook um the
vegetables for too long would they just
go a bit hard they'll go soft and mushy
okay
and then we're gonna drop the noodles
then
but now
I'm gonna make those noodles taste even
better I'd like you to put a little bit
of salt and pepper on there for me
please
next
spring onions through wash your fingers
please
we'll put a dressing on there Ginger
goes in
I can smell that from there you can
Count Me
how nice is that gonna be like a
multi-season salad isn't it no
smell
um sesame oil that's right sesame oil a
touch or sesame oil over
okay rice wine vinegar a little splash
okay
and then finally
and it will touch
soy sauce and let you drizzle that in
please
that's it
one little final
ingredient what's that seaweed whose
favorite is that Jack's Hollies
slice it into strips
okay I'm gonna chop that
oh how is that
yeah I want you to sprinkle that on top
of the noodles
and I'll squeeze the lemon juice
oh excuse me
because I had a lemon shower today
silver noodle salad is ready now
we'll get on and cook the salmon
oh it looks good doesn't it
boom let's go
boom right pan nice and hot what did I
show you when you put fish in the pan
which way did you put in
he puts it in um
skin down that's right and then there's
the pan there and you put it in there
and you lay away from you if you lay it
towards you what happens it will spit at
you it will Splash that's right so take
your time good girl
good girl
and the last one good girl very slippy
very slippy
this one's so fresh nice nice a nice
little bit of Ginger on there now a
little bit of garlic it smells of a
mixture of all the flavors doesn't it
so a nice color on the salmon
nice and sexy nice and crispy that's
right
I mean I'd like you to pour the rest of
marinade over for me please
nice
okay now the Santa's gonna glaze now
well done you're getting good at this
cooking stuff you know that would you
like to be a chef when you grow up yeah
really would like to have your own
restaurant one day I might have a bakery
a bakery me and Jack are planning on
opening one together oh and you do the
paninis and make the coffees and I do
the cakes in the cookie then it's gonna
have like scrambled eggs for breakfast
so you've already thought this out yeah
we were planning it the other night and
when we couldn't sleep and who's gonna
be the head chef and who's gonna be the
sous chef no we're not gonna do that
because we've both got different rolls
in it oh I see this is well thought out
yeah but there's We're not gonna need
anybody else apart from me and him so no
other people that was nice sounds
amazing
you got the spoon here like this okay
and just tilt the pan I'll tilt the pan
you glaze the salmon for me please
now
very my darling uh ready
do you keep the ginger on top of it
what was your favorite type of salmon
when you were little
salmon fish cakes
oh I like those you like those
how does that look that looks delicious
I'd like you to carry that very
carefully over to the table okay and
I'll carry your noodles ready
let's go well done
so I'm fascinated with this restaurant
you and Jack are going to open yeah
is my ultimate healthy dinner it's fresh
home-cooked and full of goodness
but most importantly it's absolutely
delicious
[Music]
so we have a delicious Terry for salmon
with sober noodles
and sounds super healthy
I think we did well high five and if you
would say done boom thank you
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
over the years I've had great fun being
rude about vegetarians but today I'm
joining them I put together a fantastic
breakfast lunch and dinner packed with
amazing tastes textures and full-on
flavor without a bit of meat in sight I
guarantee My ultimate vegetarian food
will have even the most committed
Carnival drooling and begging for more
first up a real treat of a meat-free
breakfast pear and crunchy granola
muffins
for the perfect vegetarian lunch crispy
golden halloumi courgette and Herb cakes
halloumi cheese doesn't look that tasty
but once you've got color on it it's
really delicious and my youngest
daughter Tilly joins me in the kitchen
to make a scrummy three-course veggie
dinner that's my guilty pleasure is it
really courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto and for put white chocolate and
lime mousse with crushed raspberries
wow that looks really cool the
dinner first the perfect morning treat
for vegetarians and carnivores alike
pear and crunchy granola muffins
something quite nice when you walk into
friends or family's house and you smell
muffin bean bags the flour and the
baking powder in a nice touch of
cinnamon
cinnamon muffins goes brilliantly pinch
of salt that's really important for the
sort of overall flavor you don't want
the muffin to be too sweet muscovado
sugar that's a refined brown sugar
really rich and somewhat spicy and goes
brilliantly inside the muffin and then
my crispy granola
so now we're gonna put half of this in
now and save the other half to sprinkle
on top of the muffin give that a really
good mix
in the center I have some fresh pear top
and tail of the pears
really important to peel nothing worse
when you're trying to enjoy that muffin
and you're negotiating with a big sliver
skin of pear
slice them around the core
sides
a slice them nice and thinly
generally muffins contain around half
the fat and sugar of cupcakes
once the dry ingredients are mixed
together you add in the wet
two whole eggs
nice milk in
followed by gently melted butter
give that a good mix
[Music]
add that to your mixture
start folding
always do it by hand muffins are
delicate dainty little beasts don't
overwork your muffin mixture you want
that mixture to become nice and relaxed
now the mix looks nice and creamy
that's right
and your little cups
and Spoon in that mixture
two-thirds full
one nice generous spoon
you can tell the mix is right because
you've got that even distribution of the
pear running from the top to the bottom
just gently tap your tray both ends
that gets the mix all the way down so
they cook nice and evenly
take your granola now sprinkle that on
top so you've got this dual texture
spicy pear and this nice crunchy topping
makes the muffin taste and feel a little
bit more luxurious now into the oven at
180 for 25 minutes
uses
[Music]
they smell delicious
got that nice crispy top just get them
out and let them cool down
and I don't have any problems turning
vegetarian once or twice a week
when I'm having muffins like that
nice
smell amazing
[Music]
a vegetarian breakfast to put hairs on
your chest pear and crunchy granola
muffins
that is a Vegetarian Delight beautiful
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you a stunning
vegetarian lunch and dinner
first here's a more in-depth look at the
key ingredients you'll need for them
first for dinner I'm using risotto rice
risotto is a flagship classic in Italian
cuisine but is widely believed that the
Spaniards introduced it to Northern
Italy back in the Middle Ages there are
three main types Arborio kanaroli and
violoni their ability to absorb liquid
and flavor whilst releasing lots of
starch is what makes risotto uniquely
delicious and anxious
a tasty creamy and inexpensive way to
satisfy lots of tummies without a morsel
of meat in sight
[Music]
the Deep dramatic red color of sweet
earthy beetroot makes it difficult to
outdo in terms of all-round culinary
impact
but early forms of this humble room veg
were carrot shapes and favored for their
medicinal rather than their cooking
merits today there is a veritable
rainbow of beetroot types to be enjoyed
pickled in soups grated into cakes or
even simply roasted which is how I'll be
using mine in my amazing vegetarian main
course risotto
[Music]
firm springy salty cheese with its roots
firmly in Cyprus and Greece the better
Lumi is made from sheep's milk rich in
vitamins and essential nutrients is
thought to promote longevity
halloumi keeps for many months if stored
unopened in the fridge and its high
melting point makes it brilliantly
adaptable perfect for grilling barbecue
and frying I'll be championing this
texture lending Marvel for my yummy
vegetarian lunch dish of halloumi
courgette and Herb cakes
[Music]
as a chef I'm never sniffy about cooking
with vegetables because I know that with
a bit of care and attention they can be
turned into something absolutely
stunning for my ultimate vegetarian
lunch I got a couple of fantastic
recipes
lightly fried my delicious halloumian
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and Watercress salad
it's cherry tomatoes are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes Vine
tomatoes are good or even just big
normal plum tomatoes lay the tomatoes on
the tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
if you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight to be honest
the longer you leave them the better
they taste
once you've seasoned them with salt
sprinkle over with some sugar
on the salt and sugar combined speeds up
the drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little thyme flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact for 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the Skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes
place your Tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees C and cook long
and slow for an hour and a half
now paluma cakes there's something quite
exciting about halloumi cheese it's a
very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
[Music]
fill the carrots
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette
the secret is keeping it all grated the
same put that into a sieve
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi halloumi cheese
doesn't look that tasty but once you've
got color on it in the pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water from the veg and we'll see
all that water that needs to come out of
there if we didn't do this it will make
your little patties non-fryable because
the whole thing starts to separate and
then mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian I like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
and parsley minted coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavors play off each other
next
two eggs in give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry
out any excess moisture mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now if you wait until you've
cooked them it'll be too late to adjust
the seasoning
roll them to a large golf ball shape
them like a little mini burger
you can spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes and it's something that can
be done up a day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes
pan on get that nice and hot boss and
wait for that I'll get the dressing
ready
slice of red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
the sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
got that sweet sour spicy flavor with my
chili dressing done I can start frying
off my halloumi cakes in a hot oiled pan
look at that nice crisp Edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the courgettes and
carrots smells delicious really
important for a nice amount of color on
them
as my cakes Sizzle away I can finish off
my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be the
Watercress just cut off stalks
[Music]
shallot rings
Watercress and shallot
they're brilliantly well together
looks so dainty when you open up these
little ringlets
[Music]
don't forget to turn your cakes
now Tomatoes whatever you don't use just
jar them and put them in the fridge
[Music]
um
just drop those slow cooked warm
Tomatoes over the Watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious little drizzle of age of
ultimate vinegar gives that tartness to
the watercress
Watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
to five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it and then tilt it to the side
because I want the garnish I don't want
the juice
and if that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night I honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
Herb cakes with a Sumptuous roast tomato
and Watercress salad all of the flavor
would none of the meat
when I was growing up my mom was a very
very good cook so we had some great food
but it was always meat and too veg and
the veg definitely played a bit past but
the more attention you pay to cooking
vegetables the more you realize they can
easily take Center Stage for all the
flavor with none of the flesh here's my
ultimate vegetarian dinner
first a hearty starter a bruschetta with
ricotta and succulent griddle courgettes
for my main I'm serving fragrant roasted
beetroot and Thyme risotto
[Music]
but I'll be in trouble with the kids if
I don't do it but
so I'm enlisting the help of my youngest
Tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
so if you unwrap the chocolate start
breaking up in Little Bits we're going
to make the most amazing white chocolate
mousse our first job is to bring half of
our cream up to the boil so
is
that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich chocolate
mousse what's your favorite sort of
chocolate is it white milk dark
I love white milk
I absolutely love milk chocolate
is it really here we go cream in
so that goes in there now you can see
what's happening straight away can't you
it's melting really quickly melting
really quickly so okay oh excuse me at
least your jumpers white so you won't
spot it yeah
in another Bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks the
lime cuts the sort of richness of the
cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
Zenith you're absolutely right next add
to the melted chocolate mixture
because I'm whisking it's just getting
lighter and lighter and lighter
have it all taste
nice yeah the line gives it a really
nice taste Tilly I need the rest for the
mousse
I need some for my tummy no come on
chocolate mousse into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites this is where I need you at
your absolute best okay because to whip
those whites it's going to be really
tough so we'll take it in turns 30
seconds each okay you go first
10 seconds gone
come on silly 15 seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two one and change
excellent hold the ball right
go no wave
[Music]
Matilda
you can't do that to me 30 seconds
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
still not very happy in there so
a contentious whipped egg whites will
make our mousse light and Airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cooled white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets the egg whites keep
the cream nice and fluffy and you get
this nice light mousse in the bowl now I
need you to crush some raspberries
please with some fresh mint
[Music]
take your mousse
wow that looks really cool now look at
that down the bottom there now
delicious
in the door please our yummy white
chocolate mousse will take at least two
hours to set so we can crack on with our
Mediterranean inspired vegetarian
starter griddle courgette Ricotta and
mint bruschetta for this recipe you'll
need a griddle pan an essential piece of
kit for that char grill look
cut thick slices of chapata bread
drizzle both size with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimeter thick
pieces drizzle and coat in olive oil and
season with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the courgettes are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty to your pasta with
dollops of minty Ricotta and top with
your seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto we need to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
shallots please into the pan for Daddy
add a Sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic once you start cooking the
risotto it's really important to have
your stock
gently boiling away if we're adding cold
stock on top of the rice all the time it
just slows down the process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of Cooks at different temperatures
that's a vegetable stock
you can't have different
chicken stock I made that mistake once
putting beef stock in the vegetarian
soup
now I didn't Matilda
I'm positive I'm joking
throughout the time how nice is that
smell it smells delicious rice in that's
a bit of a different rice this is
Arborio rice it's a perfect rice for
risotto now it's really important to
sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stock in without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for Daddy
no flambe on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
I'm adding red wine
followed by the first Ladle of stock to
get things started now we're off
[Music]
what's happening to the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it in that's right so the rice is
actually getting nice and plump
one of risotto is live when it's like
this now we can't stop cooking it we
have to cook it all the way okay ready
for the next Ladle I'm ready good girl
here we go Ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
beetroots
pilton rub them a little bit of salt and
sugar yeah and a little bit of age but
vinegar in there roasted them I'm a
great
my parmesan
how's that Rice doing rice is doing good
no
no where you want to be now look at that
nice glossy textured rice so beetroot I
want you to put two thirds of the
beetroot in there for me saving one
third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
again and then we're just going to get
some nice butter in there
butter gives the risotto a really nice
gloss look at that beautiful
let that come down let it come down
first
all right get your spirit in there
enough Daddy
there you go good wonderful shaking
risotto should be like lava
just
flows out and then the rest of the
beetroot on top
[Music]
some extra virgin olive oil
I'll pick up the bruschetta you take
that to the table
okay
Let's Go Daddy
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta
an anxious roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto
and put an indulgent white chocolate and
lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries Phoebe Jack
a delicious non-meat feast that will
have vegetarians and carnivores fighting
for seconds tonight is vegetarian nights
Megan how is it done really tasting I
love it I really like making the risotto
and we had fun
so where's Holly
it's not very nice
cheers everybody no meat vegetarian
vegetarians
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
foreign